nous l'obtiendrons jamais ne l'obtiendrons jamais ne l'obtiendrons
jamais ne l'obtiendrons jamais ne l'obtiendrons
jamais ne l'obtiendrons jamais
regarde-le quoi que ce soit à propos de ce qui semble
normal à sa recommandation donne du lourd bien
il n'y a pas de retour de cette maman
mieux vaut sauvegarder  mec Oh Calvin c'est moi Bob
alors je te connais Robbie nous sommes des connards du
lycée Oh mon Dieu alors regarde toi tu es
plus comme 200 livres qu'as-tu fait j'ai
juste fait une chose dont j'ai besoin non j'ai
travaillé six heures par jour chaque  jour pendant les
20 dernières années consécutives, vous devriez savoir
une chose à propos de
je suis à la CIA est-ce que vous plaisantez avec moi en
ce moment
j'ai un plan qui
pourrait nous faire tuer tous les deux mais si ça marche
ce sera une histoire totalement de patron
cool non je  n'était pas cool il y a
trois semaines, un ennemi de l'État
qui a volé les clés de cryptage de l'
ensemble du programme de satellite espion américain
buh-buh-buh ne le fais pas arrête ça arrête
tu appellerais ce gars  l'école tu es
mon seul ami Calvin tu es le
seul au monde en qui j'ai confiance maintenant
que tu es à l'école je n'y suis pas je n'y suis pas mais
ils pensent que tu l'es mais je n'en suis
probablement pas un  de ces perceptions par rapport à la
réalité, les choses qui se passent en ce moment
balles
quelle voiture nous la prenons pas celle-là oh mon
dieu oh tu as choisi d'être un [ __ ] international de la
CIA sur les intimidateurs en ligne tu es
comme Jason Bourne et George ouais tu te
souviens de ces backflips l'habitude de faire
allons  fais le flip qui était si près de
toi